[Musique]
bio tout le monde sait squeeze ça
c'était ma réponse à la première
question comment allez-vous moi ça va
très bien je suis très content pour deux
raisons la première c'est que ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas parlé vous et
moi qu'on n'a pas fait une petite faq on
en fait une par an c'est peu mais
suffisant
la deuxième c'est que c'est bientôt les
vacances pour moi aussi je suis très
content ça va me faire du bien j'ai
besoin de faire une pause pour revenir
plus fort je suis content de faire cette
faq et j'attendais de la faire parce
qu'il s'est passé énormément de choses
pour moi cette année vraiment des trucs
bien des gros changements dont j'avais
envie de parler et quoi de mieux que
d'en parler lors de cette faq je suis
très excité la wii en plus un format que
je faisais en 2013 donc je vois bien un
squeeze 2013 pendant la faq je vais
mettre à crier à faire du web
je t'avais déjà envoyé un pic sur ça
mais à quoi un flop en turquie frérot tu
sais pourquoi
comment ça tu sais pourquoi évidemment
parce que c'est un pays magnifique j'ai
hâte de m'y rendre pour visiter les
ruines du temple d'artémis prendre en
photo la cascade de murat d'y faire un
peu de camping dans les forêts dié nice
ou encore passer un moment hors du temps
dans la cité antique ok pour la calvitie
ok je vais y aller un jour comme à calvi
sur a progressé urban tu arrêtes tu les
as dicton premier album sortira en
septembre
on veut en savoir plus alors j'ai eu des
tas de questions sur l'album ce qui me
touche je vois que ça suscite la
curiosité et j'ai hyper envie d'en
parler mais ce sera pas dans cet
effectif
pas de panique ce sera deux prochaines
vidéos bas j'ai tellement de choses à
dire sur l'album est aussi d'anecdotes
marrante qui concerne la création de
l'album que je vais faire une vidéo
dédiée à ça ok spécialement sur le sujet
qui sortira la dans les semaines à venir
d'ici deux ou trois semaines et qui
répondra probablement à toutes vos
questions et plus mais là j'ai pas envie
que ça cannibalise cette faq ya beaucoup
de choses dont j'aimerais parler donc
voilà prenez votre mal en patience ça
arrive vous en faites par petit
débriefing sûreté tatouages et des
autres en cours eux non non non j'ai la
flemme wells nous intéresser les
derniers les derniers il ya eu celui ci
que j'ai fait en même temps que celui là
c'est très dur de remonter son bref vous
manquez pas ça c'est une carte je
voulais trop enfermé que ça c'est un
oiseau je voulais trop en faire un
discours de l'herbe
c'est la même artiste qui a fait celui
ci est celui ci j'ai enchaîné les deux
je crée jamais dû elle a fini je me suis
levé l'entièreté de montceau va dans mes
jambes je devient tout blanc et je suis
en train finalement de faire un malaise
oh oui vous pouvez rire et elle voit que
je suis blanc et immobile et que je suis
dans le mal elle me dit oh toi tu vas
pas bien toi allez assis toi je t'amène
une bouteille d'eau et tu vas attendre
30 minutes
voilà donc une tatouée ce qu'ils me
tatouer a dû faire la maman avec moi
puisque je trop faible
ça m'a mis mal mais les tatouages sont
beaux jeux très content étant donné que
tu concrétise beaucoup de gros projets
tels que ton premier album musical et
dioko as tu eu pour ambition te séparer
progressivement de youtube à l' avenir
plus ou moins lointain
pas du tout j'en parlerai dans la vidéo
dédiée à l'album mais c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui était dur avec l'album c'est que
quand je fais des projets je veux en
aucun cas que ça entrave
ce que je propose sur ma chaîne youtube
principal et même les lives et la chaîne
secondaire j'ai une vision assez spécial
sur ça en fait je veux que tout ce que
je puisse faire en terme de projet ce
soit du bonus par rapport à ce que je
fais sur ma chaîne youtube et twitch je
veux pas du tout que ça vienne remplacer
des vidéos ou des live parce que j'ai
totalement conscience que ce que les
gens aiment avec le nom squeeze c'est ce
que je propose sur la chaîne youtube et
dans mes lives et c'est pas forcément ce
que je peux faire à côté par exemple ya
plein de gens parmi vous je suis sûr
qu'ils adorent regarder les vidéos etc
et c'est génial merci et qui sont
patrons les couilles que je sors des
musiques qui n'ont même pas les écouter
et y'a pas de mal à ça j'ai juste
habituer les gens à des vidéos et à des
live pendant des années je peux pas d'un
coup arrêté ça pour leur proposer autre
chose et c'est même pas ce dont j'ai
envie en fait j'ai envie que ça vienne
s'ajouter à ce que je fais déjà mais
c'est ça qui est compliqué du coup est
ce que tu penses adopté un ami à jumbo
et natsu alors figurez-vous que oui puis
que non je suis désolé vous venez divin
ascenseur émotionnel
en fait j'ai beaucoup réfléchi je
voulais trop adopter un chien pour
quoique natsu est un ami je sais pas
j'ai eu ce délire et puis je me suis dit
que je crois que je suivrai pas d'avoir
un deuxième chien un chien c'est déjà
tellement de responsabilités et ce qu'on
déchire vous savez dans l'immédiat là
avec tous les projets que j'ai tout ce
qui est prévu et c'est sur la saison
2020-2021 aussi je peux pas me permettre
d'adopter un second chien du coup j'ai
pensé à adopter un chat parce que je
suis beaucoup chez moi et que ça demande
moins d'investissements qu'un chien en
plus ça ferait un pote à jumbo de natsu
jumbos aime bien mais jumbo c'est pas un
chat qui joue c'est un chat qui dort et
qui veut des caresses et j'ai découvert
les servane sait déjà qui comme les
bengals ont un caractère très très
particulier très joueurs etc et je me
suis dit [ __ ] ça peut être un bon
compromis pour apporter un ami qui soit
autant un ami de jumbo qu'un ami de
natsu je suis très investi dans les
relations des animaux as tu remarqué que
tu disais toujours cette phrase pas du
tout du tout pas du tout pas du tout pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout pas du
tout pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout c'est énervant
sécher à 10 secondes je n'en peux plus
c'est ça que vous vivez en regardant les
vidéos
arrêtez de regarder c'est pas trop dur
de vivre pour le moment non en mesurant
un mètre soixante dix c'est mieux qu'un
remède 69 et tant que j'ai la taille
requise pour faire toutes les
attractions qui existe quel est le
problème
à caen
jamais ça cgem est ce que pour toi la
crise sanitaire était un frein dans
certains projets une sorte de pause pour
décompresser ou au contraire un boost en
termes de créativité
écoutez je fais partie de ces gens qui
n'ont pas du tout mal vécu le
confinement en fait déjà tous les
streamer et youtube heures on a eu trop
de chance avec le conflit non parce que
ça nous a pas impacter
professionnellement là où beaucoup de
gens ne pouvais plus aller travailler
voire même était en suspens et n'avais
plus de revenu tout le monde était sur
son ordi et tout le monde à les
consommer de youtube ou des live donc
déjà professionnellement il n'y a pas eu
d'impact pour nous on attendait on est
les grands gagnants on a eu beaucoup de
chance et à côté de ça j'avais beaucoup
beaucoup de projets à finir dont l'album
d'ailleurs et grâce au confinement et
autant du coup à dispo que j'avais d'un
coup puisque tous mes rendez-vous été
annulé tout mon planning été annulée
d'un coup j'avais tout mon temps pour
faire des vidéos des lives et bosser eh
ben j'ai pu avancer sur tous ces projets
donc moi je suis rincé horrible mais je
l' ai vraiment pas mal vécu je m'en veux
ni vos amours là dessus at il trouvé
l'amour de sa vie
alors non mais il essaye de le trouver
apparemment récemment je me lève un
matin et natsu à son kiki sortie et il a
même une boule une énorme boule et je me
dis oh là là son sexe va exploser
vraiment naïvement je me dis ça en fait
c'est juste la gueule que son pénis
ah mais je l'avais jamais vu à voir donc
bref tout ça pour vous dire que je
panique je l'emmène immédiatement chez
le vétérinaire en me disant [ __ ] mon
chien un problème au pénis c'est chaud
je méconnais pas un pénis de chiens et
la vétérinaire me dis bah à lucas en
fait juste il est en chaleur de malades
et ils allaient les glandes qui se
contracte et normalement c'est ce qui se
passe quand un chien vient et fait
l'amour en chaîne et donc avec lui se
passer ça sauve qui avait pas de
femelles donc c'est trop triste
il avait tout la réaction que tu es sans
savoir quand il ya une femelle milliards
et femelles et puis voilà peut-être
qu'un jour je lui préfère des petits
seins ça se trouve ça rejoint mon projet
d'avoir un autre animal d'ici deux ans
c'est quand que tu réussis une activité
manuelle
elles sont toutes réussi à chaque fois
[Musique]
je comprends pas ce que tu veux dire
logiciels see you tube s'arrête demain
tu voudras toujours faire vendeur chez
micromania
alors non j'ai fait un truc autour du
jeu vidéo professionnellement parlant
avec les vidéos youtube donc je veux pas
faire la même chose en moins bien en
revanche chez micromania si gmail
youtube s'arrête je pense que si tout
s'arrête j'en profiterai pour faire un
truc qui n'a rien à voir j'aurais
utilisé mais ce qu'ils en activité non
je sais pas honnêtement je sais pas mais
je pense que je fais un truc qui n'a
rien à voir après j'espère que ça
n'arrivera pas attention je n'ai jamais
dit que je voulais ça arrive salut salut
quand tu fais des vidéos activités
manuelles
est-ce que tu continues certaines
activités seul son film est parfois à
aucun moment ce n'est jamais arrivé
en fait le principe des vidéos exit est
venue elle c'est d'oser faire ce que je
n'aurais jamais eu le courage de faire
s'il n'y avait pas le contexte de la
vidéo en gros ça ne faisait pas une
vidéo avec sur la chaîne youtube
je suis vraiment et gris dans ces vidéos
est stressé parce que c'est vraiment des
trucs qui me stresse des activités
manuelles faire des choses avec mes
mains essayer d'être appliquée soigner
tous essam stress vraiment mais c'est le
principe de ces vidéos là et as tu des
activités que tu as préféré la poterie
lemieux coucou est ce que tu penses
refaire un expert jours j'avais adoré
sur the last guardian ou encore une type
d'armes alors voilà la bise c'est les
anciens ça qui me parle de let's play
alors oui bien évidemment ça se passera
pas sur la chaîne principale ça se
passera sur en live sur twitter et donc
ensuite en vod en bestof sur la chaîne
gaming et on en a fait un d'ailleurs
l'année dernière sur cette même chaîne
youtube sur man of madame qui est un jeu
créé par les mecs qu'on fait une petite
dame est cette année en septembre ou
octobre via little hop qui sort un autre
jeu créé par les créateurs de until
d'harnes et donc je le ferai dans l'exp
bien évidemment en plus c'est une
histoire un peu d'horreur et tout donc
voila vous en faites pas levé ce plan
continue mais j'avoue j'en fais pas
assez j'aimerais en faire plus tu t'es
toujours épanouie sur les réseaux sinon
pourquoi si oui pourquoi pas du tout je
me suis même jamais épanouie sur les
réseaux en fait j'ai vraiment du mal
avec les socios non pas que je trouve ça
j'ai envie de critiquer ça et je trouve
ça nul comme concept est ou pas du tout
je partage déjà tellement de choses sur
youtube que j'ai pas envie de partager
l'entièreté de ma vie sur les réseaux à
côté de ça par exemple un stage j'essaie
d'être actif en ce moment parce que je
culpabilise cueilli aussi millions de
gens dessus et que je propose rien c'est
honteux mais j'ai pas ce réflexe naturel
de tout partager tout le temps en story
de faire des photos à mettre en poste
dur et où j'ai pas le réflexe quoi donc
je le fais parce qu'il faut le faire
mais j'ai pas réflexe j'ai la même que
twitter m'a fait beaucoup de mal à une
certaine époque ce que c'est dur de
prendre du recul sur ce qui peut se dire
sur toi mais c'est sait plus sur youtube
et twitter que je vais beaucoup
m'épanouir et pas sur les réseaux
sociaux en fait un cache-cache 2-2 prévu
cache-cache de ça fait deux ans que j'ai
trop envie
le faire sauf qu'aucune marque n'a
accepté de sponsoriser le concept donc
c'était en stand by en a fait un format
qu'on a adoré faire que vous avez adoré
regarder mais qu'on peut pas continuer
parce qu'aucune marque veut mettre
l'argent pour qu'on puisse le faire et
bien écoutez c'est même pas moi qui ai
contacté une marque c'est eux qui m'ont
contacté
rino chiffres qui font des coque du
téléphone m'ont dit j'ai eu un choc je
me suis dit mais attend ce jour est
arrivé ce jour irréel
donc je suis très content et il y aura
bien cache-cache de enfin après deux ans
d'attenté autour du mois d'octobre
logiquement qui arrivera sur la chaîne
et je suis très content en plus j'ai eu
des idées de catch est folle ça va être
très très drôle tu trouves toujours le
bonheur dans ce que tu fais oui et toi
enac
en vrai c'est une bonne question et je
pense que c'est dur de continuer à avoir
du plaisir dans ce que tu fais quand tu
le fais depuis très longtemps
moi je suis souvent pris de passion pour
des choses de manière intense pendant un
certain temps et puis d'un coup ça me
saoule complètement et je passe à autre
chose donc ma chaîne youtube c'est un
peu un miracle parce que c'est un ça
fait neuf ans du coup je fais des vidéos
et ça m'a jamais sous les comme la vidéo
c'est un truc assez large
en fait ça englobe beaucoup de choses
différentes et donc du coup je me suis
jamais trop là c'est parce que j'ai fait
évoluer les formats trouver des nouveaux
concepts et c'est chez page c'est l'un
des rares truc que je me lasse pas et
aussi je pense que ce qui m'aide c'est
le fait d'avoir d'autres trucs à côté
c'est de faire des live sur des jeux
vidéo puis ya aussi la marque qui a
encore autre chose et puis l'album duck
ou carrément septembre qui est encore
autre chose la musique ça n'a rien à
voir et le fait d'alterner entre toutes
ces choses fait que je trouve toujours
autant de plaisir dans chacune d'entre
elles voilà donc oui ce taux toujours
bonheur dans ce que je fais et le jour
où je serai plus bonheur dans ce que je
fais j'arrêterai et je ferai autre chose
ta carrière a beaucoup changé pour le
mieux bien évidemment tu prends plus de
plaisir et ça se voit donc si tu pouvais
donner un conseil à squeeze plus jeunes
c'est quoi va voir un coiffeur
voilà c'est assez évident quel est ton
rapport aux médias
on te voit très peu à la télé à la radio
dans les journaux sauf récemment sur nrj
avec toi lui c'est un choix si oui
est-ce que ça a quelque chose à voir
avec ton passage dans salut les terriens
ou pas du tout mais pas du tout faire
déglinguer sur un plateau télé pendant
40 minutes ne crée aucun traumatisme
lors d'un autre livre s'appelle tourner
la page de vieilles peurs quant aux
femmes soient incapables de savoir
comment ça fonctionne tout ce qui est un
média plus classiques on va dire donc
télé radio magazine presse écrite etc
quand tu fais ça c'est souvent pour
faire de la promo sauf moi je n'ai pas
besoin de faire de la promo pour mes
vidéos fin je m'en fous écoutez qui sait
dans le cadre de la promo pour l'album
peut-être que je vais revivre ardisson
deux sèvres est un grand moment de
plaisir encore une fois salut squeeze ça
va très bien et toi ça n'a pas trop été
difficile de gérer tout ce stress pour
les clips cette année au même de gérer
les vidéos pendant le conflit
ça va parce que tu nous a lâchés du
quasi lourd avec ton clip cougar je sais
pas ce qui me fait le plus rire ses
cougars au lieu de départ ou quasi lourd
genre c'était presque l'ours que j'ai
lâché c'est dommage
comment tu fais pour pas devenir fou est
resté muet avec toutes les personnes qui
cherchent la petite bête h 24 je deviens
fou
évidemment je deviens fou mais je le dis
pas je n'en parle pas en fait tous les
youtube heures les instagram heures bref
tous les gens du web sont des
personnalités publiques
et quand et personnalités publiques
c'est implique forcément que des gens
donnent leur avis et disent des trucs
sur ce que tu peux faire transmettre etc
et c'est normal en fait c'est le jeu
alors il ya un côté frustrant ou c'est
vrai que dès que tu vois un truc passé
qui est infondée ou purement du fake bah
tu as envie de répondre tu peux pas
faire ça pour tout ce qui se dit donc
faut juste accepter le fait d'être une
personnalité publique et se dire bon
basse par rapport à tour des gens qui
diront des trucs sur moi qui n'iront pas
dans mon sens et c'est normal en fait il
n'y a pas de joie je trouve pas ça grave
salut peut-on savoir son implication
dans la marque dioko qu'est ce que tu
fais est ce que tu comptes faire à
l'avenir
la marque on la crée avec mon frère du
coup le 3 juillet 2019 donc elle n'a eu
un an
récemment bonne anniversaire yoko en a
sorti un an cinq collections en comptant
les deux du lancement donc on a bien
bossé je suis très content mon frère est
directeur artistique c'est celui qui
design les vêtements mois en fait j'ai
un peu superviseur c'est à dire je vais
donner mon avis sur les vêtements sur
les thèmes à aborder dans les
collections par exemple sur le thème des
masses traditionnel c'est moi qui avais
dit à mon frère j'aimerais bien qu'on
aborde ce thème
et puis mon frère ensuite bas par dans
le thème si ça n'inspire ou pas yoko
aujourd'hui on à former une vraie équipe
l'a récemment il ya des trois derniers
mois une équipe de cinq personnes qui
bossent à plein temps sur la marque et
donc on va cette année avoir un rythme
de une collection tous les deux moi
c'est des drops du coup en quantité
limitée genre en ce qu'on fera jamais de
réapprovisionnement quand il y en a plus
y en a plus et il faut attendre le drop
suivant et donc je supervise un peu tout
et surtout là où je m'éclate le plus
c'est pour faire les fameuses vidéos
promos des collections c'est moi qui les
gèrent et hauts bonnets avait réalisé la
première au lancement ensuite on a effet
km puis récemment pour mélodie en 3d et
ça m'éclate parce que ça permet de
proposer du contenu sur la chaîne
youtube dans lequel je ne suis pas au
premier plan mais non je suis content là
le prochain spot est le meilleur de tous
jouent spoil c'est le meilleur de tous
de très loin je suis très content même
la collection le thème l'angle en fait
de la collection est vraiment cool on
est particulièrement tous faire de cette
collection là qui sortira vers la
rentrée donc voilà je viens de vous
montrer ça mais non voilà pour résumer
mon application en gros je suis
superviseurs et est gérée du coup
puisque c'est moi qui mets la marque en
avant que voilà je suis très très fier
et fan de mon frère je suis trop content
dioko pour ça c'est une [ __ ]
d'aventuré
j'espère que la prochaine collection
vous plairont j'ai constaté que tu ne
tournait plus à ton studio depuis le
confinement est ce que
c'est un choix personnel ou est ce que
les studios sont inaccessibles les deux
ans dans le confinement j'ai dû tourner
des vidéos de chez moi parce qu'on
n'avait plus le droit de sortir dont je
pouvais plus aller à mon studio et en
fait j'ai adoré ça je sais pas j'ai vécu
un truc de retour aux sources où je vais
dans mon bureau chez moi je lance la cam
j'allume deux pauvres light tranquille
j'ai adoré ça en fait je crois que les
vidéos où je suis seul je préfère les
tournées chez moi que détourner dans un
espace dédié à sa un espace du cou qui
est beaucoup moins chaleureux que mon
chez moi où il ya un truc très officiel
j'arrive ya des rails avec des lumières
frein tg pas c'est sa sacralise le
moment du tournage et ça me stresse
tournée chez moi je suis en mode pas les
couilles j'adore en fait et la
transition immédiate vers cette question
pourquoi rester associé à wedia plutôt
que de monter une structure indépendante
et bien écoutez j'ai quitté webedia qui
est le network la régie commerciale avec
laquelle je travaillais depuis quatre
ans pour finalement prendre mon envol et
devenir 100% indépendant et il se trouve
que mon studio
celui là il était chez webedia c'était
dans les bureaux de webedia donc ayant
quitté le network bah je vais pas aller
dans le studio et continue à tourner là
bas alors que je suis plus chez eux et
comme j'ai lyoko le projet musique est
bas les vidéos les opex tara qui
continue je me suis dit ben vas-y je
vais louer des bureaux et tous ces gens
qui sont des amis aborder des gens avec
qui je travaille je vais les mettre dans
les bureaux avec moi et j'aime créer mon
petit paul de bienveillance et de jean
stylet avec qui je vais bosser et être
100% indépendant dans mon coin
c'est donc aussi là bas que je vais
faire mon nouveau studio dans lequel je
vais pas tout est en tournée comme je
vous ai dit j'adore tourner de chez moi
mais là bas je tendrais les vidéos
activités manuelles et vidéo à plusieurs
et peut-être quelquefois les vidéos seul
si j'ai envie de tourner là bas mais ce
sera surtout un point de ralliement pour
bosser sur yuko pour bosser sur des op
pour bosser sur les prochaines vidéos
avec lucioles et là je me doute que vous
avez envie de voir cet endroit est bon
il fallait de l'audace est parti hop là
cette transition jamais bien vrai dans
les nouveaux bureaux
je me tiens là quel métier puisque je
suis ému le studio dans lequel on
entendra des vidéos à plusieurs etc il
est allé taj ici il ya d'autres choses à
commencer par les futurs bureaux locaux
oui c'est en travaux c'est en travaux en
fait je voulais trop que l'équipe yoko
et donc mon frère soit dans les mêmes
bureaux que moi tout simplement est donc
ici on aura une sorte d' open space où
ils seront là avec leur bureau en train
de créer des vêtements quoi j'ai jamais
aussi mal utilisé un truc c'est horrible
et voilà je suis très content parce que
je vais voir mon frère tous les jours on
se voit pas assez donc jeu très content
florent je t'aime espaces suivants
évidemment justice et à droite ce sera
le show room yoko un champion que c'est
à dire un endroit où on verra toutes les
collections yoko même celles qui sont
plus disponibles et qui étaient là l'an
passé en trois à cool de faire un show
biz qui nous servira aussi des espaces
pour faire des shoots photos ici ce sera
le bureau de mon manager de la personne
qui va gérer tout mais dopé avec les
marques et qui est censé normande leur
apporter un maximum d'euros par
conséquent voilà ici ce serait un petit
box pour stream et je sais que des fois
je serai en retard le jeudi pour live où
je sais que des fois j'aurai envie de
live tout simplement et donc je vais
faire un petit espace ici de stream avec
un fond vert un truc pour que puisse
live d'ici quoi sans avoir à rentrer
chez moi donc ça c'est le
rez-de-chaussée donc trois espaces en
cours pour iphone 4 est là haut c'est ce
qui vous intéresse
c'est mon studio bienvenue à laitages
ici se trouve mon studio
mais avant une petite terrasse de
manière à déjeuner c'est tout c'est tout
mon ami terra devant j'ai pas besoin
d'expliquer qu'on s'en fout ils ont
retiré le sol ça fait un bruit c'était
et c'est très désagréable
ça c'est mon nouveau style donc je suis
content parce qu'il ya une hauteur sous
plafond suivre alors un badge jimenez
incroyable mais vrai c'est cool parce
que l'espace est assez grand là ça
résonne beaucoup donc on va devoir mai
des trucs acoustique pour ça résonne au
loin mais ici ce sera le bureau de
lucioles de lorraine qu'il connaissait
très bien maintenant juste ici ce sera
un espace pour tourner les vidéos à
plusieurs et aussi les activités
manuelles je pourrais les tournées ici
et ici les gars à temps avant de montrer
qui parmi vous kiffe les petits espaces
restreints un peu en mode grotte
moi j'adore ça ne vous parce que quand
j'étais petit mon bureau se trouvait
sous la mezzanine et je mettais une
couette qui pendaient de ma mezzanine et
ça me faisait une sorte de grotte je
suis seul à avoir vécu ça
[Musique]
ça c'est mon studio il est petit en
hauteur il est petit en largeur longueur
et je me sens trop bien j'adore ce truc
de petits espaces je pense qu'ici je
vais mettre une porte coulissante je
crois ou un rideau je m'aperçois contre
mes 6 ans et maintenant royaume a changé
donc voilà vous êtes déçu mais je sais
pourquoi je n'ai pas de panique une
cuisine je sais que vous êtes déçu que
vous auriez aimé voir à quoi va
ressembler l'espace quand tous les
travaux seront finis et où ils seront
pas finis avant mi septembre
voilà spoil mais je vais quand même que
vous sachiez que j'ai pris mes propres
bureaux et c'est aussi parce que je dois
attendre les travaux se terminent que je
tourne tout chez moi actuellement il y
aura plusieurs vidéos que je vais
tourner ici mais comme j'ai dit la
plupart je continuerai à les tourner
sûrement courir chez moi parce qu'en ce
moment je kiffe
et puis dans six mois je vais changer
d'avis et je vais tranquille et venir
tourner ici bref mais voilà j'ai enfin
mon espace à moi dans lequel je vais
mettre toutes mes équipes pré mans qui
montre une vidéo il ya en alsace donc il
viendra pas mais voilà il y aura du sua
il y aura à tulio qu il aura mon frère
car mon agent est en lambeaux de secours
stream aura tout ce dont j'ai besoin à
dix ponts et puis voilà ça fait bizarre
d'avoir son espace à soi et 1 personne
notre quoi et je change d'environnement
quoi mais je suis hyper excité ça me
fait trop plaisir et je sais je vous en
faites pas je vous montrerai comment
l'espace sera fini je crée des stars du
genre en pleine vidéo mais je vous
montrerai tout ça mais voilà maintenant
il faut qu'on passe à la prochaine
question comment penses-tu faire un
épisode de jeu surprend 8 abonnés au
tour du monde
j'ai vraiment envie de faire un épisode
2 de ça parce que c'était l'une des
expériences sans même parler de youtube
et d'excellence professionnelle l'une
des expériences humaines personnelle des
plus incroyables que j'ai pu faire dans
ma vie envoyé cette vidéo je vous dis la
vérité j'aimerais la faire chaque année
tellement c'est une expérience de ouf de
faire ça tu vois des paysages tu
rencontres des gens qui te suivent
depuis des années tu vis un truc intense
avec des potes qui sont l'équipe
technique 1 mais ça reste des amis avec
qui je fais tout frais de voyage
j'aimerais leur faire le souci c'est que
cette vidéo là elle a coûté 180 mille
euros ça fait beaucoup d'argent pour une
seule vidéo qui en plus était pas
sponsorisé j'ai pas envie de sponsoriser
ce format piste et pour les 10 millions
façon aucune marque n'aurait jamais
lâché au tour d'argent pour une vidéo
mais c'est quand même beaucoup de temps
et d'argent et du coup bah je peux pas
le faire chaque année
mais j'aimerais bien leur faire pourquoi
pas pour les 15 ou 20 millions ça vous a
profondément marqué c'était incroyable
donc j'adorerais le faire et bien
écoutez c'est la fin de cette fois en
question qui était bien nécessaire
[ __ ] il s'est passé tellement de
choses cette année j'espère vous voyez
plus clair dans tout ça c'est vrai je
suis resté assez flou sur tout ce qui
est passé cette année dans le berceau et
dans le pro il y avait tellement de
choses qui se sont passées en même temps
que voilà il fallait que j'attende le
bon moment pour en parler le bon moment
c'était cette foire aux questions je
suis soulagé là je viens d'accoucher
d'un sacré truc là en vrai je suis
content j'ai fait ce n'est pas trop
chiant dans tous les cas on aura appris
plus sur l'habitat natsu et ça je pense
ça fait plaisir à beaucoup de gens ce
n'est pas la dérive idéaux de la saison
il reste quelques vidéos dont la fameuse
vidéo qui parlera de l'album qui sort en
septembre j'ai hâte j'ai hâte j'ai hâte
de vous parler de tout ça mais ce sera
dans quelques semaines je vous dis à
bientôt prenez soin de vous reposez vous
bien pendant ses vacances et je me sens
bien je suis content d'avoir parlé avec
vous voilà pas très vite
[Musique]